over the Thanksgiving break I read this
book by Bob Woodward fear Trump in the
White House when it came out in
September the snooty elitist on the East
Coast salivated over his juicy gossip
trump watches TV a lot and the story it
told of a president they see as an
ignorant dangerous barbarian here's a
few of the condescending highlights it
is a stunning look inside the Trump
presidency
exposing a chaotic White House led by a
man who has said he believes the key to
power is fear I think that what Woodward
has presented here is a devastating
portrait Brooke we've heard about chaos
we've heard about dysfunction but the
details in this book are like nothing
we've ever heard before all the
anecdotes certainly ring true to the man
we know and the man who never evolved or
stepped up when he won the presidency oh
my gosh
right the East Coast elite held up this
book as evidence of why Donald Trump is
not fit to be President well either they
haven't read the book or they're
deliberately distorting what's in it
what Bob Woodward has actually done is
write a book in praise of President
Trump the wouldwould account in fact
tells the story of a president who is
totally focused on his agenda clear
about his priorities and obsessed with
delivering the promises he was elected
on but blocked at every turn by almost
everyone around him former chief of
staff Reince Priebus former economic
chief Gary Cohn former Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson current defense
secretary general matters and especially
Rob Porter the White House staff
secretary who resigned in disgrace over
wife-beating allegations these men were
in president Trump's inner circle and
they literally plotted and schemed with
each other to overturn the result of the
2016 election Donald Trump's signature
issue for decades has been trade he was
elected to get out of TPP NAFTA and
other trade deals that hurt American
workers he couldn't have been clearer
about it we are going to start
the TPP totally renegotiate NAFTA one of
the worst trade deals ever made by
mankind and protect every last American
job from day one the president wanted to
deliver on that by introducing tariffs
and renegotiating trade deals but
globalists including Gary Cohen and
general mattis did everything in their
power to stop him another central theme
of Donald Trump's campaign was his
promise to stop America's involvement in
endless Foreign Wars I will never send
our finest into battle unless necessary
and I mean absolutely necessary and will
only do so if we have a plan for victory
with the capital v and yet the
globalists and his team tried every
trick in the book to get the President
to break his promises and carry on with
the failed policies of the past it's the
same on immigration one of the most
distinctive elements of the Trump 2016
agenda was its promise to end the
elitist consensus for uncontrolled
immigration that for decades delivered
cheap labor to big business Republicans
and easy votes to establishment
Democrats could anyone have
misunderstood what Donald Trump was
saying as far as the wall is concerned
we're gonna build a wall we're gonna
create a border we're gonna let people
in but they're gonna come in legally
they're gonna come in legally and it's
something that can be done but on this
issue too we learned from Bob Woodward's
reporting that far from undermining
democracy as the East Coast elites
scream every day president Trump has
been battling to uphold democracy by
delivering the policy changes that
people voted for far from describing an
unfit and clueless idiot in the Oval
Office the Woodward book portrays a
clear-eyed and resolute president
fighting exactly the elitist enemy he
was elected to fight the only problem is
the enemy is within not just within his
own administration but within his own
White House now some of those people
have gone Rex Tillerson Gary Cohn Rob
Porter they're out but far too many are
still
there next week we'll be in DC right in
the swamp and we will bring you a
special edition of swamp watch the swamp
in the white house yes we will name
names you do not want to miss it the
swamp in the white house next Sunday
from DC tell me what you think of all
that at Steve Hilton X and that next Rev
FNC